in the morning dame crested gave every
impression that she was fully confident
that she had uh the respect and indeed
the confidence of the mayor of london uh
clearly things changed
yeah well firstly may i just pay tribute
to the 40 years public service that dame
crested dick has given to the people of
london and the uk as a whole it's been
exceptionally difficult circumstances
but of course she was the first woman to
hold the role she's done some amazing
work in
broadening the diversity of the met and
making it more representative of the
people of london and the people that the
met serves i just like to pay tribute to
that at the outset and clearly however
there have been a number of issues that
have happened on her watch that have
caused
great concern for people of london of
course the uk as a whole and those will
very much need to be addressed i think
it's a little bit of a shame that things
have happened the way that they have um
it appears that uh clearly the
relationship has broken down
between the mayor and between uh the
mayor and of course uh dame crested and
that is a shame uh but i think what
we've got to do now is to focus on the
future and to start to address all of
the issues that will cause the people of
london concern
so what happens now as regards the post
off commissioner as i understand that
dame creston will remain in post in the
interim but we need to get the job
sorted as soon as possible don't we when
might that happen
so there are processes in place uh that
will be followed and they're well
established the home secretary makes a
recommendation to her majesty the queen
and i that will be taking place over the
course of the next few days and weeks
i'm sure that everybody involved will be
very aware of the importance of getting
this critical role filled as soon as
possible
indeed and not least because of course
the metropolitan police are currently
investigating the government i mean what
does this mean for the state of the
investigation into the dining street
parties
so the police are very used to uh to
handling matters where there are
different parties involved they're
totally independent i have absolute
confidence in their ability to uh
operationally uh carry out an
investigation uh so they will do that
they'll do that in a way that is uh that
is independent and that will not be
affected by the the the role at the top
of the net
sure
given what we have seen over the past 24
48 hours as regards crested dick in her
position is now not the time for the
maid of london the person in charge of
the city to have complete control over
who is the
of the city's most senior police officer
so there's a quite well established uh
procedure here um where because it's
such an important role
that it was the met of course have roles
beyond just london they also have roles
uh that touch national security as well
so it's right that the home office also
has its uh level of involvement as well
so home secretary clearly has some key
interests here for the whole of the uh
uk
but yes that relationship with the mayor
is clearly key uh between the mayor and
the chief police officer within uh the
city uh within london itself uh that's a
key relationship it's always important
that is but the structures have been
well thought out and are well practiced
uh and we have been through this of
course before and replacing uh met
commissioners in due course
you well indeed i mean
when the prime minister was made of
london he got rid of off syrian blair i
suppose the question isn't all of this
though if pretty patel had had her way
crested dick would still be metropolitan
police commissioner well all the way
until the end of the the additional two
years that the home secretary signed off
on
well as i say i think it's a bit of a
shame that the relationship has broken
down between the mayor and dame
christopher dick in the way that it has
because uh it clearly is now an issue
that has to be resolved on top of all
the other many challenges that the met
has um because it's absolutely
unacceptable that there is any
suggestion of any uh racism or
homophobia or anything that that
detracts from public confidence in the
met so that is something else we'll have
to deal with on top of that that's
regrettable but we are where we are uh
and i think we need to look to uh look
forward to the future
so sorry to pick you up on it but it is
a phrase you've used a couple of times
in the interview in what way is it a bit
of a shame that the relationship between
the mayor and the police commissioner
broke down
well clearly it's a key relationship
isn't it between the mayor and the
mayor's chief police officer it would be
better if that had been handled in a way
that meant that the relationship hadn't
broken down but it clearly has uh both
parties have said that um so i'm just
acknowledging the fact that that
relationship has broken down which are
which is uh regrettable but as i say we
are where we are we need to look at the
future
sorry to sorry to keep pushing on this
but the the reason that crested stepped
down according to her is that the maid
of london did not have confidence in her
we hear from within the mayor's office
from within city hall that he was not
pleased with the plan that the chief the
commissioner of the metropolitan police
had come up with to put the mets house
in order it was a failure on her part
according to the maid of london rather
than a breakdown in the relationship
well i think initially the mayor had
given her longer than she's had to get
that uh plan in place it was originally
going to be uh weeks and now of course
it's come down to a very short space of
time a matter of days and that's why i
say it's a it's a bit of a shame that
that is the case um but i i couldn't
comment any in any more detail as to the
reason why the mayor has lost confidence
and that's his position to obviously
have to ask him about that um clearly we
have to look to the future now make sure
the issues that uh that can affect
public concern uh within the matter
addressed